[Musique]
salut le résultat du premier tour est
passé pour les élections présidentielles
ça c'est fait et c'est une bonne
occasion non pas de commenter les
résultats mais de parler de notre
système de vote en france système de
vote qui ne va pas qui déconne
clairement alors pourquoi il déconne
est-ce qu il ya d autres solutions
alternatives
j'ai creusé le sujet avec hugo de la
chaîne hugo décrypter david de la chaîne
science étonnante et vous allez voir que
quand je prends ça avec un esprit
critique et scientifique le système des
élections en france et pas si
démocratique que ça
[Musique]
en france pour la plus grande des
élections l'élection présidentielle on
vote en deux fois pour notre candidat
préféré premier tour et 2e tour au
premier tour il ya plein de candidats au
deuxième il y en a que deux il pourrait
y en avoir trois dans une situation
particulière mais en général c'est que
c'est un système uninominal
on ne vote que pour une personne s'est
pas toujours le cas c'est pas toujours
en deux tours il ya d'autres formes
d'élections comme ça dans le monde par
exemple en angleterre il ne vote qu'en
un seul tour donc c'est hyper violent
mais ça oblige les parties se mettent
d'accord en amont avant les élections et
non pas après comme il est en train de
se passer en ce moment là c'est un cas
en plus particulier quand le front
national est dans la course à une
coalition naturel qui se met toujours en
place mais peu importe quand on regarde
les dernières élections après les partis
font leurs petites affaires entre eux
pour essayer de récupérer les voix des
uns des autres c'est ce qu'on appelle
les stratégies c'est l'un des défauts
majeurs du système actuel est ce qui a
deux défauts derrière c'est la question
que j'ai posée à david haye les défauts
du système actuel bas on voit à chaque
élection c'est le côté couperet du
passage du premier ou au deuxième tour
et qui fait que finalement les candidats
qui vont être qualifié pour le deuxième
tour des fois ça se joue à pas grand
chose
et donc ça conduit principalement à ce
comportement qu'on appelle le vote
stratégique ou du coup les électeurs
choisissent de ne pas voter selon leur
conviction la plus profonde c'est à dire
qu'ils choisissent de ne pas voter
parfois pour le candidat qui préfère
celui qui voudrait sincèrement voir élu
et choisissent de voter pour un candidat
qui est mieux placé et dans l'espoir
d'éviter un candidat qu'ils estiment
encore pire au deuxième tour donc c'est
le principe du vote utile et on voit
bien que le problème du vote utile c'est
que il va naturellement pénalisé des
candidats qui ont été au départ déclaré
comme plus petits c'est à dire que des
candidats dont on estime qu'ils n'ont
pas trop de chances de gagner et s'est
notamment très orientés par les sondages
du coup se trouve pénalisé par le vote
utile et donc les candidats qu'au départ
on déclare petit belle sont condamnés à
rester petit en d'autres mots l'idée de
voter pour un programme on est déjà en
train de voter en imaginant le 2e tour
et en se protégeant plus ou moins de ce
qu'on aimerait voir ou pas au deuxième
tour c'est quand même dommage mais ça on
n'y reviendra pas ce qu'a également
d'autres problèmes le problème aussi
c'est le vote blanc ce fameux vote blanc
il est plus facile de faire entendre sa
voix en n'allant pas voter
l'idéal d'ailleurs c'est d'être inscrits
et de ne pas se présenter aux bureaux de
vote qu'en votant blanc parce que depuis
quelques années on a admis que le vote
blanc existe et qu'il ya des gens qui
votent et blanc on a écrit des trucs
pour ça on peut trouver l'info de
combien il ya eu de votes blancs mais il
ne pèse pas du tout dans la balance on
fait une élection au suffrage universel
faut avoir
50% des voix au deuxième tour pour être
élu aux élections précédentes françois
hollande avait eu 52 % des votes mais on
n'avait pas pris en compte les votes
blancs
si on avait pris en compte les votes
blancs donc l'intégralité des votes vote
blanc inclus faisant le 100% alors ils
n'avaient que 48% des votes
en clair il n'y avait pas de président
élu au deuxième tour aux élections
précédentes situe vous pouvez juste
synthétiser ça en quelques mots s'il te
plait ça lui hugo ça lui va bien alors
en france le vote blanc c'est assez
particulier et aujourd'hui si tu votes
blancs ton vote devient pas grand chose
tu as droit de voter blanc en glissant
une enveloppe sans bulletin ou alors
avec un bulletin mais sans nom dessus
mais en réalité ce n'est pas très utile
en effet si effectivement le nombre de
votes blancs est annoncé aux résultats
des élections aujourd'hui on sait pour
la présidentielle et pour le premier
tour combien de personnes ont voté blanc
pour autant ils ne sont pas prises en
compte sur la présidentielle par exemple
aujourd'hui 100 % des voix sont répartis
entre les onze candidats sans compter
dans le pourcentage le vote blanc c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle je
rends la campagne tu as pu entendre
certains candidats à militer en faveur
de la reconnaissance du vote blanc
reconnaissance du vote blanc ça veut
notamment dire par exemple que c'est une
majorité des électeurs votent blanc
l'élection est annulée alors que donc je
me répète mais si important si jamais on
a une majorité des gens qui votent blanc
en france c'est toujours le candidat qui
a le plus de voix qui élu président et
oui il a raison de dire que c'est
important si vraiment on était genre 80%
la population à aller aux urnes pour
voter blanc ça n'aurait aucune incidence
donc quelqu'un qui ferait 50 % des voix
ne ferait en fait que 10 % du vote
global ramenait des chiffres comme ça on
se rend compte que oui c'est un vrai
argument de programmes de reconnaître
aujourd'hui de football en france
mais revenons à nos petits candidats
enfin ce qu'on appelle les petits
candidats c'est quand même terrible
qu'on qu'on détermine comme ça qui sont
les petits et grands candidats je vous
ai expliqué il ya quelques minutes mais
vous l'avez compris que nous mêmes on
est déjà stratégique dans notre manière
de voter simplement parce que notre
système est mauvais il est mauvais parce
que toute notre raisonnement politique
on le donne d'une manière complètement
erroné en choisissant une seule personne
sur un bulletin
et ça ça ne peut pas traduire ce qu'on
pense de chacun des candidats je pense
que vous qui regardez cette vidéo et que
moi aussi on est plus nuancée qu'un seul
choix alors la vraie solution c'est que
comme il ya onze candidats on doit
organiser 11 tour mathématiquement c'est
ce qui tient le mieux la route au
premier tour chacun vote pour l'un des
onze candidats on voit celui qui a le
moins
de vote parmi les onze on le retient du
game et on refait un tour d'élection en
votant sur les dix candidats restants et
cetera c'est une espèce de mort subite à
chaque fois le dernier est éliminé et
ont fait autant de tours qu'il ya de
candidats ce serait la meilleure
alternative
le problème c'est qu'elle a un défaut
majeur évidemment on le sentait venir
c'est à dire que on semaines d'élections
c'est un peu compliqué mais surtout
faire bouger on soit les gens aux urnes
ce serait extrêmement compliqué en
admettant que la personne se soient
inscrits à la vente puisque en france il
faut s'inscrire avant le 31 décembre de
l'année précédant les élections pour
pouvoir aller voter et ça aussi je fais
une parenthèse dessus mais je comprends
bien que ce soit compliqué à mettre en
place mais aujourd'hui il faut changer
ça c'est beaucoup trop tard je pense
qu'une majorité des gens au mois de
décembre s'occupe de noël non pas une
vraie conscience politique à ce moment
là et à force de voir des débats à la
télévision ou de lire dans la presse ou
d'entendre parler commence à s'y
remettre à vouloir s'intéresser et
veulent s'inscrire beaucoup trop tard
alors je vous entends déjà dire dans les
commentaires
oui mais c'est un droit c'est un devoir
on s'occupe pas de la politique quand ça
nous arrange peu importe peu importe en
fait c'est juste important que tout le
monde puisse aller voter et c'est
possible de le faire dans ce système
suisse par exemple tout le monde est
inscrit sur les listes je crois les
suisses dites moi si je me trompe et il
ya une obligation d'aller voter un
cetain c'est une obligation bas au moins
c'est réglé c'est obligatoire mais il
n'y a pas à se poser la question est-ce
que je vais voter pas voter ce que je me
suis inscrit pas inscrits alors le cm
que je vous propose est donc il est pas
terrible sur une semaine mais il existe
quand même d'autres alternatives ya le
système irlandais qui est intéressant
pour lire le président en irlande sur un
bulletin on fait un classement de tous
les candidats
ça s'appelle le volt alternatif et
s'assit nul en fait un petit peu le
nombre de tours dont je vous parlais
alors on se dit mais pourquoi on
n'utilise pas ça c'est juste formidable
parce que là aussi un problème il ya un
problème sur les trois quatre derniers
plus on monte plus mathématiquement il
ya des parades au xi qui peuvent se
créer dont le paradoxe d'arreau qui fait
qu'à un moment donné dans une
configuration particulière à trois
quatre ou cinq candidats une personne
peut s'auto pénalisé en ayant trop de
voix si elle a trop de bonne voie dans
son classement c'est à dire en premier
alors elle peut laisser passer quelqu'un
devant bien comprendre ça je vous invite
à regarder une vidéo que vous mettrez en
lire dans la description qui est faite
par david de sciences étonnante c'est ce
qui m'a fait le contact et puisque quand
je faisais mes propres recherches je
suis un moment tombé sur sa chaîne et
j'ai vu qu'il avait traité ce sujet
l'année dernière déjà dans les autres
systèmes qui existent aujourd'hui il ya
celui des etats-unis alors j'ai demandé
à hugo s'ils pouvaient concrètement nous
expliquer la différence entre les
etats-unis la france pour le vote est ce
qu'il existe vraiment d'ailleurs une
différence entre tous les pays au final
les différences elles sont très
nombreuses et entre tous les pays la
principale différence c'est que la
france ait lieu au suffrage universel
direct
alors que les états unis élise au
suffrage universel indirect aux etats
unis c'est différent à l'échelle les
états fédérés les électeurs vont élire
des grands électeurs qui vont eux-mêmes
ensuite élire le ou la présidente des
états unis et d'ailleurs ce système
indirects qui a permis l'élection de
donald trump près de deux millions de
personnes en plus seront votés pour
hillary clinton
mais c'est bien trump qui a été élu
président comment l expliquer et bien
son parti le parti républicain a réussi
à obtenir une majorité des voix dans un
certain nombre d'états important où le
nombre de grands électeurs enjeux
étaient importants ces grands électeurs
ont donc élu trump dans la foulée il est
devenu le président voilà pour la
différence principale entre les
etats-unis et la france mais ça peut
être intéressant de voir deux systèmes
de vote alternatif on peut notamment
citer deux que je trouve assez
intéressant le jugement majoritaire et
le vote préférentiel c'est ça ce que tu
viens d'appeler le vote préférentiel
c'est ce que moi j'appelle le vote
alternatif mais tu viens de parler du
jugement majoritaire et c'est très
intéressant c'est selon moi est selon la
plupart des gens qui travaillent un
petit peu sur sur le raisonnement sur
les mathématiques sur tout ça le
meilleur système de votes possible david
a très longuement travaillé sur ce sujet
également est ce que tu pourrais nous
résumer le jugement majoritaire en
quelques mots le principe de la méthode
du jugement majoritaire bc plus de
mettre un seul bulletin dans l'urne
comme on a l'habitude avec notre système
classique avec un seul nom dessus mais
c'est de donner son opinion sur tous les
candidats c'est à dire que tous les
candidats ont valeur attribuée alors on
pourra leur attribuer une note mais on
dans le système du jugement majoritaire
ont choisi plutôt leur attribuer une
mention
donc il ya typiquement cette mention
donc ça va de a rejeté jusqu'à excellent
et puis chaque électeur doit attribuer
une mention à chacun des candidats donc
on donne son opinion sur vraiment tous
les candidats alors comment à partir de
ça ensuite on détermine le vainqueur
eh ben pour chaque candidat on regarde
le pourcentage qu'il a obtenus dans
chacune des mentions
et puis on regarde quelle est la mention
que 50% des gens seraient prêts à lui
attribuer donc c'est très simple on
trace un petit graphique comme ça on
tire a trait à 50% et sept mentions la
baisse et la mention que 50% des gens
seraient prêts à attribuer à ce candidat
ou alors il serait prêt à être mieux que
ça et c'est ce qu'on appelle la mention
majoritaire du candidat et donc le
système à la fin est très simple chaque
candidat reçoit une mention majoritaire
et c'est le candidat qui a la meilleure
mention majoritaire qui est élu et si
j'avais plusieurs candidats ont la même
mention bon on peut regarder les
pourcentages pour pour essayer de les
départager
l' avantage de ce système c'est qu'on se
prononcent indépendamment sur chaque
candidat donc il n'y a pas de notion de
vote utile ou de phénomènes
d'interférences parce qu'un petit
candidat va venir gêner un gros ou
simplement en fait le concept de petits
candidats n'existe plus 20 ans tous les
candidats sont placés sur un pied
d'égalité
et donc ça donne la possibilité aux
électeurs de s'exprimer sur tous les
candidats et ça peut donc
potentiellement permettre à des
candidats qui seraient considérés comme
comme petit au départ en fait de
recueillir des mentions tout à fait
correct et donc c'est une manière de
corriger certains des problèmes du
système actuel bas une manière ou même
la manière de corriger puisqu'on le voit
il ya plus de petits candidats
et là il n'y a pas de système de
classement ça ressemble un petit peu au
vote alternatif mais y'a aucun
classement
on doit nous en notre âme et conscience
donner notre avis sur chacun des
candidats et ça c'est très concret parce
qu'en plus ça nous oblige à nous
intéresser complètement au programme ça
veut dire que tous les candidats
réfléchir et sûrement leur programme
plutôt et le publierait plus tôt et nous
ça nous responsabilise aussi à le lire
puisqu'on doit donner notre sentiment
sur chacun mais comme il n'y a pas de
classement on ne peut pas être
stratégique en tout cas pas complètement
puisque l'aca assez peu d'incidences au
final les deux tours qu'on fait depuis
des années dans cette cinquième
république font que au premier tour on
choisit un candidat
concrètement et au deuxième tour on
élimine celui qu'on ne veut pas parmi
les 2 restants c'est aussi notre
candidat fétiche reste si on prend en
compte le fait qu on s'oblige nous mêmes
avec stratégie pour pas voir ça ferait
un candidat au deuxième tour que le vote
blanc n'est pas reconnu que les petits
candidats gêne les gros malgré eux
évidemment mais à ce moment là et leur
prennent des voix en tout cas sur les
qualifications qu'on rajoute également
qu'on doit s'inscrire sur les listes
également cinq mois avant le début des
élections ça fait beaucoup de choses qui
prouve que le système électoral en
france est périmé mais j'ai simplement
péri mais enfin ça c'est ma pensée ça
n'engage que moi je vous
dans les commentaires à me dire ce que
vous pensez vous aussi en étant
évidemment respectueux des avis de
chacun ça doit rester de l'ordre du
débat d'idées et non pas de qui a la
meilleure insultes mais je pense
sincèrement qu'on peut profondément
réformer le système pour qu'il soit
réellement démocratique et en même temps
de réellement responsabilisant pour les
citoyens voilà ça me tenait à coeur de
faire cette vidéo je pense qu'il ya un
lien direct avec le mentalisme encore
une fois puisque on a regardé avec un
esprit critique en retournant un petit
peu la situation dans tous les sens des
élections c'est aussi ça s'intéresser
aux choses et comprendre comment
fonctionnent les choses
exceptionnellement pour ceux qui sont
encore là je vais vous dire de quoi va
traiter la prochaine vidéo et bien la
prochaine vidéo ce sera l'énigme pour le
gagner par contre je veux que la
personne qui gagnent ce trophée le gagne
vraiment et un sentiment de yes je le
méritais je ne vous dis pas quand il
sort je ne vous dit pas à quelle heure
elle sort certains noms déjà déduits de
toute manière comme toujours vous pouvez
laisser un pouce et vous abonner et
rendez vous très bientôt ciao
[Musique]